i saw like eight of them in a year which
was so clean
yeah around our school i mean that's
gros that's really gross
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who once broke up with her
boyfriend because he told her he got a
boner elise morales
and with us today guys we have such an
exciting episode she is a stand-up she
is an actress she is
a literal icon but before all of that
she was a graduate of the san francisco
school of the arts it's margaret cho
hi hi thank you hello who do you have
with you today
this is um lucia catarina
lawler cho or um
her korean name is cho rucha
so you can call her cho rucha
or you could call her uh lucia katarina
um either way she really
hates social media so she's really
always really anti-streaming
podcasting especially instagram live she
hates
she does it but
glad she's with us today she really is a
facetime police
she really hates any kind
of no but she doesn't mind zoom for some
reason she's cool with zoom
um she just pooed over there i see it i
see it
i just like i didn't i can't smell it
but i can see it and i'm like
oh i see what he did she just wants me
to see it
because she's just sitting on me so
that's something you'll have to deal
with
at some point it's fine it's fine she's
so small
it's fine she's small she's tiny all
right well
margaret i'm so excited to have you on
the podcast um
yeah so like i said right at the
beginning you went to san francisco
school of the arts i'm assuming
because i know this to be true that
that's a performing arts high school
um did you have to audition to get into
that high school
yes um it's one of those things it's
like the
show fame and that's school and fame
that's what i was gonna ask audition to
get in
and there are um several parts of the
school
you have uh the um music
part uh the um the sir singers
there's um there's dancers
there's musicians there's um
actors of course there's uh visual arts
so it's a magnet school from the public
schools in san francisco
got it got it there was a school in my
area like that but for math and science
and you had to take the tj
test to get in but it was a public
school but you had to like
take a big fancy test which i did not
take because math and science is
actually not my forte
um but so when you're at this school
how was there like a hierarchy of like
well the theater kids are on top
and the band kids that's social suicide
to be the band kids or was it did you
hang out with
each other no um the uh
dancers were on top okay the dancers
the dancers were like on the social
because they were the most
beautiful i mean the dancers were like
um physically perfect
you know you couldn't get better than
the
the dancers were like just absolutely
um stunning people you really couldn't
get any better looking than these
dancers were just marvelous and then i
think the actors were probably
the second tier um because they were
also like the most dorky
like all and also the most uh outgoing
yeah and um seen steely kind of people
and also good looking and then you
probably had
um the uh banned people because the band
people were also
very charismatic you know like you had
um the kind of brooding um
piano players i mean the thing is that
we didn't have like
bad because band geeks were almost
like people in band were um
the stereotype of people in band are
from like regular schools we're talking
about like
real virtuoso yeah people who are like
really great musicians who are not
necessarily
geeky because they're such good
musicians that they sort of
transcend the idea of like band geek and
become like their own thing
they're doing it because they actually
have an aptitude for the instrument and
not because they're like i literally
need to make friends and an excuse to
finger people on a bus
yes so it becomes like a calling as
opposed to
um this sort of um
security blanket yeah so i think it's a
it's sort of a different
social um construct than
um something that like is in a regular
school
although i don't know like i think it
depends like um
what we what you use instruments for
and like what what we um so cause
sometimes like people
use like instruments like it depends on
what you use them for and what you play
um there are certain instruments that
are just
um cooler like we would
really have a guy playing saxophone
really well on the school
like the steps in the courtyard
when it was empty i mean it was
so 80s it was so so ridiculous
yeah and so i wonder like was it
how much like fame was it like how
competitive
once you're in and you've gotten into
this theater school
it seems i mean the theater at my high
school was competitive and we were just
like
a random public school so what was it
like to be like competing with your
peers on that level
um it really wasn't that competitive
because
um everybody was uh
there were there weren't that many
people so there weren't that many and
there weren't that many
um i think there weren't that many
productions there weren't that many
people there weren't that many things
that were happening that we were
competing for
so everybody kind of got a turn to do
stuff
and um you know so it wasn't it didn't
feel
as if um you were
uh in a high pressure situation
um at least it didn't seem to me to be
like that you know or like
you know the the kind of um feelings
that
were um going on had more to do with
just like regular teenage angst and
and it wasn't it i think that like that
sort of feeling of like
fame cost and this is when you start
paying and sweat had more to do with the
reality of like
a dance career would have on a young
person
and their body you know the reality of a
dance career of a young person you know
that
that's true i mean a dance career is
very
difficult for um people in their bodies
and yes
just like a music career is difficult
for people in their bodies i think an
acting career
is is not really the same i mean it is
i think in um if you're talking about
like a young ingenue on
uh in the in a movie but for like um
for somebody like myself i always
thought oh like my
um thing is like i know like because i'm
not
white i'm not necessarily an engineer
i probably will end up playing character
roles
for the rest of my life i think i'll
probably have
an enduring lifetime playing
like a judge in everything he loves
i was like i'm gonna be the judge
in every i've actually not really even
ever played a judge but i bet i will at
some point
um but i thought i i was like put it out
in the universe
let's get margaret as a judge i'll be a
judge and everything
i would actually love to be a judge in
something now but um
i would love to be in the supreme court
now actually in the parole actually that
would have been
that would be really really great but um
the
the idea of like um
you know the the short life of an artist
is
is really um more of i think geared
towards dancers
yeah than anything and it's kind of
almost a construct
in the drama of um the chorus line a
chorus line
or um staying alive yes those kinds of
movies
um so we actually have a screenshot from
a documentary about your high school
that i wanted to pull
up that you are featured in so here you
are
uh you're you're a junior in theater you
say your goal
is that you want it all yes which i
love the confidence yes and um
but with the short boot which i probably
would not wear that
but um and a legging i
actually like that shirt the shirt i was
about to say the shirt and the headband
i like it's very fashion forward
for uh the 80s and because it's actually
projecting the 90s it's paisley
and um but the boot i was like what is
that
it's kind of brown i don't know um but
i'm with sam rockwell
who has oscars that's amazing i didn't
even
i didn't even compute that so were you
ha i know aisha tyler went to your high
school
as well yeah is that correct it's tyler
um she's in that class too but she
uh she was the narrator of the
documentary
so she's actually the host of the
documentary and um
she uh comes forward later but
um he and i sam and i would end up going
um to comedy clubs and doing comedy
sketches together he was my first comedy
partner
in school but yeah he's great
um is this a picture from a play or a
show or something
it seems like you're on the stage well
we did we did a lot of like sketchy
comedy things
got um comedy we were in a comedy troupe
so um we would do these things but i
love that
font yes
it's a very inchworm
it's real like 70s but i don't know if
it's supposed to be retro i think it was
supposed to be modern at the time
maybe it was coming back the font was
taking a resurgence
so you're saying did you get into
comedy via this high school or was it
something you were
already interested in okay cool so talk
me through that journey
um so i had a teacher we all had a
teacher who
was very um proactive
in signing us up for comedy nights
at this comedy club called the other
cafe which was a very famous club
in san francisco that had shows um they
would do
shows with uh paula poundstone and um
dana carvey and um robin williams would
perform there
all these famous comedians and um she
would sign us up for the open mics
so sam and i would go and perform there
at the open mic
and we were very young we were probably
like 15 14 15.
and um it was really like inappropriate
now i think back on and i'm like that's
really inappropriate but i'm glad you
did that
yes because it's really great actually
um
because you know it sort of gave me an
into this world of
comedy and then sam ended up moving to
new york with his mom
but i stuck with it because i really
loved it and i
fell for this whole lifestyle of doing
comedy at night
and it really gave me a place to go like
i really
felt like this is the world that i
belonged in
which was true do you remember any of
your early bits or what they were about
um it was really about being there like
i didn't belong there which is
also true like i was like i don't know
what i'm doing here i'm really a kid
and that you know i'm not really right i
mean i know that
um and also the inappropriate things
that people were saying to me
like these old men like was just gross
like but also like
the protective nature that would come
out with these people and
and kind of that that feeling of like
this is very strange like i'm here with
people that are older than my parents
and like also
um that thing of not
being like anybody else there but also
kind of feeling blowing there so there's
a lot of different things happening
that um i was kind of processing
while i was there and and so i think
that that was
um in a way uh the right thing to be
doing
um talking about that very cool
so did you um did you start
out high school at the performing arts
school or
did you come there later i came there
later i was at another
magnet high school called a lowell high
school which was a math and science
school okay so i went
there first and then i went to um the uh
school of the arts later
so what made you make that switch
i had to leave the uh lowell because i
got kicked out for not going to class
because i hated it i kept cutting and
then i got kicked out because i was like
it was such a valuable school like this
the um you know there were so many
people trying to get into that school
and i was just like not and it's a
public school so i was like
not valued that i was not valuable
so i got kicked out how did you end up
at the math and science school first was
that like something your parents wanted
for you or were you just kind of like i
guess i'll go here
um well i had uh really good grades
in um junior high and um
so it was just the thing of like that's
what you do
you know when you have um a high
sort of like that everything like when
you're
um an asian american kid and
everything is like college prep there's
no like
elementary school or high school
everything is like college prep which is
like to me it's like
i don't even understand like what that
is
about like you know it's it's not
there's no
um sense of childhood or
no sense of like innocence everything is
about
college prep which is like why are you
trying to like advance adulthood
so quickly i know it's really sad
so um to me uh
that just seemed really um unimportant i
mean it was important when i was a
really young kid but then
when i became like a teenager then i was
just like really rebellious against like
i didn't want to do that
like i wanted to um be an artist and
so that's really when i decided to like
kind of rebel and not go
to class and not go because i didn't
know how to flunk out except to just not
go i mean that's a great you you were
right
you nailed it like i think so but that
was really hard for uh my family to
accept i mean i think that
you know they're still upset about it
which i think is like
also dumb
like i think that they're like um
you know they're still like kind of
disappointed but i i don't know
exactly um i mean i i mean i don't know
exactly
exactly how much better could have
turned out i i feel like yeah
yeah i was gonna say i feel like at
this point you've justified going to the
performing arts high school
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast
is brought to you by mint mobile honey
breaking up with your old wireless
provider just got a whole lot easier
thanks to mint mobile
they were the first company to sell
premium wireless service online
only and now mint mobile is introducing
their unlimited data plan
for just 30 bucks a month let that sync
in
an unlimited plan for 30 bucks how much
is your
soon to be x wireless provider charging
you
hmm i bet more for people who hate their
phone bill and are ready to cut ties
with big wireless
mint mobile offers their premium
unlimited plan for just 30 bucks a month
and if you're someone who loves your
phone bill
i don't know examine that i don't know
what that's about by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes
significant savings on w all plans come
with an unlimited talk and tax and high
speed
internet delivered on the nation's
largest 5g
network we love that 5g we love that 5g
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with
all of your existing contacts so you
don't have to do that weird thing where
you're like i have a new number and then
like
i don't know that's exhausting you won't
have to do that and if you're not
100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with a seven day
money back guarantee break up with big
wireless and switch to mint mobile's
unlimited
data plan for 30 bucks a month to get
your new unlimited wireless plan for
just 30 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door free go to
mintmobile.com teen self
that's mint mobile dot com slash teen
self
cut your wireless bill to 30 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you
by candid you know all the things we
love to do for ourselves but haven't
done for
whatever reason for me i always
wanted straighter teeth and a better
smile obviously my smile is extremely
gorgeous
all of you who watch on the youtube are
captivated
daily by it because you watch it daily
but i've wanted to make it better and
i'm done
putting it off thanks to candid
straightening my teeth is simpler and
easier and more
comfortable than ever candid clear
aligners are comfortable removable and
practically invisible
unlike wire braces so you can transform
your smile without
anyone noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an
expert on tooth movement and it's all
done from the comfort and convenience of
your own home
candid only works with orthodontists
never general dentists like other
companies not gonna name them but the
other ones they work with dentists
candid not so much plus your supervising
orthodontist will be with you every
step of the way with candid your
treatment includes more remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
i love that i love to know the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs
thousands less than braces yes
thousands start straightening your teeth
today right now all my listeners can
save 75
on candid's starter kit go to
candidco.com
teen self and use code teen
self that's candid co.com
teen self code teen self take advantage
of this
limited time offer and save seventy five
dollars on your starter kit
candid co dot com slash teen self code
teen self see this smile is actually
going to improve
soon because of candid
i put it in it's hard yeah it's hard to
i think that they're like i think um
korean people are so um
they're so trained to um
react to this idea of like um education
as being the future except
because of korea the way that korea is
and the way that the education system is
and how you have to
um really like uh be in
the education system in order to be
successful
they sort of think that that's the way
in america too the same
way here yeah so how quickly after
getting to the first high school
did you look around and be like oh [ __ ]
this isn't for me
oh it took about a year and then i was
just like i don't want to do this like i
was like
this is so gross and we also had a huge
amount
of um sexual predators
at our um school not in this school but
at around the school like for some
reason
there was like a huge amount of like
weird um it was like the 80s so there
was like a lot of flashers
like there was like a lot of like guys
like driving around
um in like convertibles like with like
trench coats like it was like super
great like weird like flash
flasher culture so your high school was
surrounded by
flashers yeah by these a weird men
who were i mean it was like i saw like
eight of them in a year
which was so clean yeah
around our school i mean that's gross
that's really gross
that would have been extremely shocking
to me i mean like i said at the top of
the pod
i broke up with a boy because he told me
he got a boner and i was like
i did not sign up for that at all
but it's so weird like things to think
about now like to think about how many
times
and it was just like you have like your
tracker keeper
and like you're peachy and then you're
like i
had to like do this so like cover up my
face so many times to like
shield myself from like the penises and
it's such a
weird thing to like just be like oh
like why are we doing this and um
there was just so much of that and it
was just such a weird
time to like kind of feel like why
why is this school like so
so much about why is this a problem at
this school and um
also uh there was just i mean the
culture of the school was just so much
about academic um
like excellence we have to like be like
we have to
we have to excel we have to excel we
have to excel
we have and all of it was so much
forward thinking about like what college
are you going to go to what university
wasn't college it was university
what university and it was all ivy
league and if you're not in an ivy
league
then the only other option is stanford
and if stanford was like a step down
and it was like what you know what
universe are we
you know like that's too much pressure
to be under i couldn't
i couldn't do it okay going back to the
penises for one second
it did the school address this with you
at all or were they just like
we're talking about college and whatever
you saw on your way to get here
leave it at the door margaret
no no that was just something that you
just sort of
dealt with like it was just another
thing that
was part of your uh
like you just like you just dealt with
it like it was just like part of your
life like it was just
oh that that's just that that's just the
reality of being a kid
in the 80s you know that is so wild to
me
um so okay you you're skipping school
at this point what would you do when you
were skipping like where would you
go oh i would we would go like it was
actually me and a bunch of other kids at
our school like it was like not just me
that was
um rebelling against this school it was
like a bunch of kids at that school
and you know because um it was a kind of
a trend
of um
like a lot of us were losing
faith in that sort of system of so it
was a lot of asian american kids who
were just like i'm not doing this
so it was like a a bunch of us who were
like this is
[ __ ] and losing the idea of like
i i can't i i i can't i can't endure it
and i can't i can't
i can't be part of this and so and then
everybody sort of like went their own
way whether it was
um going and buying alcohol
at like some weird like liquor store
that would sell to like 14 year olds or
like going and
um going and uh
to like um punk rock shows at night
or you know dyeing your hair or
um you know whatever it was there was
like some kind of like rebellion that
you were pursuing
everybody had their own form of it and
so when the
when the expulsion finally happens
what like how did your i mean i'm
assuming your parents didn't take it
well but what was the transition like
from like
you get expelled to then you moved to
the performing arts high school did you
decide right away or was there kind of
like a weird in between time
oh um no i decided pretty much like
during the expulsion period like i
decided before i got expelled that i was
gonna go there and then i started
preparing for
going there um like i started to like
prepare for my audition and deciding
like
i think i decided before i was expelled
even that i was gonna go
and then i was i was like preparing like
to audition
and preparing to um get an
agent actually i was trying to like get
an agent to go to
um start to go to like castings for
modeling and for um
like a a commercial agent and like i was
starting to like try to be
um like a
you know like to get like commercial
work and stuff like professional stuff
like headshots and all this stuff like i
was trying to like do
um team catalog modeling and trying to
do like all the stuff like i was trying
to be very
like ambitious and um
trying to do that kind of stuff so there
was um this
burst of activity where i became very
independent
and i was trying to like do things of
like oh i'm going to be like a child
star
but i'm not going to have my parents do
it i'm going to do it myself so there
was this thing of like
um i got very sort of ambitious and
started doing things on my own and um
that was really uh i think
what was really exciting because i was
like
becoming very sort of um
motivated to do that but i i started to
like
memorize um monologues out of these like
audition books and
and you know decide of what like what i
was gonna do for like these
um auditions and um so that that kind of
thing
that's super interesting because to me
the the act of doing that to be like i'm
gonna be an actress i'm actually gonna
be a
model i'm actually gonna be a child star
there's so much like
confidence and self-assuredness
in that that is yeah unique for a
teenager
yeah do you were you confident or
self-assured in other parts of your life
or was it just like no i'm gonna be a
famous person but i'm so nervous talking
to
anyone i have a crush on yeah
i mean i knew that i could probably do
that
like i think i don't i don't know like
why i thought i could do that like i
just thought like i
i i guess there was a couple of jobs
that i got that
like early on that made me feel like oh
this is like
possible i don't know i don't know what
it was there was just something about it
that
there was a couple of jobs that were
really
big that i got that were like like i
remember i got like this
job that was like extra work that was so
um it was so meaningless
but it was like but this was like in the
80s but it was for four thousand dollars
and it was like i was like oh my god but
it was extra work yeah
but but it was still like it was a
that's a lot of money in the 80s
and it was only it was like featured
extra like a thing and then i was like
i did another extra job this was a
little bit later on it was in a movie um
and it was for uh um it was kind of i
think i got cut out but it was kind of a
it was it was in a scene with um julia
roberts oh my god i
called up forever young with a director
who just died a joel schumacher
and um and it was on clement street it
was in san francisco
and uh so they specifically specifically
cast
me in it so it was kind of like this
thing like it was like
this whole thing where i was in stuff
like that
so i specifically cast in things so this
is a little bit later on but
that there was this confidence that came
forward even if i wasn't
speaking in roles or i wasn't i was i
was still able to get
jobs that were like kind of legit even
though i wasn't like an actress yet
you were getting just enough
encouragement that was like you gotta
keep going like you gotta keep moving
and rolling along
very cool um so
okay during this time
what is your are you dating at all do
you have i mean i'm assuming you have
crushes
i know oh yeah yeah i know you're
bisexual so did you have crushes on
girls at that time were you in tune with
that part of yourself
yeah i think that i was probably much
more of um
like i i definitely had well i had a
boyfriend when i was 15
but he was very um like
i feel like he he was more um feminine
i definitely had sort of more of a
connection with
people who were maybe i guess in the 80s
who would be
they would they wouldn't be not now they
would be non-binary
got it but then then they didn't have
that sort of
modern language yeah you didn't have
that so now i see them as sort of
more like gender fluid is or non-binary
but um back then they didn't have that
sort of like
title um i think uh
and then in the 90s i was definitely
very
like lesbian and like real angry about
it
that to me is much more embarrassing as
to being like angry lesbian
because when you get like those long
jean shorts and then you won't stop
coming out like you won't stop
like like i was like get like really
long bike shorts
like jean shorts and like a big bike
chain with like big blinks
and like i wouldn't take it off a really
like big
messenger bag so i always had like stuff
like like
hanging off of my body like really heavy
things
yeah it's like very very like when
you're like wearing a lot of heavy stuff
and you're like a lesbian like you're
really angry about it and you're like
i'm a strong
lesbian and i carry my clothes with me
yeah and you won't take off your boots
it's like really heavy it's so annoying
it's like a really heavy like weighted
down
so i just didn't like it so
when you when you were in high school in
the
80s there was obviously no language
about being non-binary but what was your
understanding of your sexuality at that
time were you like oh my god i'm
bisexual or were you just like i don't
know girls kind of make me feel away
but i always do too like it was weird
like i remember that there was this boy
that would come to school all the time
and he would dress like madonna
and i would be like wanting to talk to
him and ask him like
what is going on like
what and because people would always
hassle him but i wanted to ask him about
it but i also didn't want him to be like
hassling him because i didn't want him
to perceive it as
me hassling him yeah you were like i
genuinely am curious about the madonna
yeah i'm genuinely i'm like i wanna i
want in on like i wanted in on it
because i wanted to dress like madonna
too but i also wanted to
be a part of what he was doing
like it was like this thing of like i
want
in on this identity but i also
don't want to hassle you i don't want to
be perceived as
being like um an assault on you because
i know that this is an assaultive
position because all you know is this
sort of assault
on your being there's another guy who um
would dress as prince all the time okay
so and then i didn't understand how come
like the guy that dresses like madonna's
getting hassled but the guy that dresses
like prince is not getting hassled
because they look exactly the same
that's very true and also there's a
really i mean i guess it's a performing
arts high school so i shouldn't be
surprised but
it feels like a lot of work to dress
like a pop star
every day yeah and but they but they're
like
the only thing that puts like the
guy dressed like madonna and the goddess
like prince apart
is the guy dressed like prince has more
lace
yes yeah like the guy dressed like
prince has like a
a full lace rough where the guy left
stress like madonna doesn't have a lace
wrap like yeah just a tasteful bustier
yeah it's like the weirdest thing of
like why
is the you know it's like the guy
dressed like prince has
even more of sort of a louis of the 14th
like even more
flamboyant thing like it's a very
strange kind of thing
of like what is feminine and what is
masculine and what
where does this divide come and
um when the feminine is actually
quote-unquote more masculine yes
so it's weird no that's really
interesting and it makes sense to me
that you were drawn to the madonna kid
because it's like here's this person
who's
kind of being very openly queer at a
time
when i imagine that wasn't happening a
lot
now i know you said that people hassled
him but do you feel like
at the performing arts high school there
was maybe a little more room for people
to be
openly gay or was that just really not
happening
i think i think there was and that there
wasn't i think because
it was the performing arts school there
was more queerness
on display but because it was
youth there was a lot more insecurity
about it
so there was a lot more defensiveness
around it
you know like there was a lot more of
like um
people um like really
uh very
um defensive and very
um like uh there was
some homophobic violence there was a lot
of like
crazy [ __ ] like um
things going on that were really
unpleasant underneath it because i think
that
there was stuff that was like um
kind of i think uncomfortable because
because there was so much
so much happening underneath the surface
um i think when you're really like
around a lot of like young people
like the the the sort of like thing of
like
we're because it wasn't like harvey milk
high school
where everybody is like openly queer and
like we're like
here as a safe haven yes because this is
like
the 80s where it wasn't necessarily
like okay to be gay even san francisco
people think
oh well it's like a queer city
but san francisco has a real
conservative undercurrent
even though it's like a you know
supposedly this sort of like
very like sodom by the sea
it's really i wish it was
it's actually just one kid dressed as
madonna
kids by nature are very fearful and very
like
conservative in a lot of ways you know
and yes
that sort of doesn't go away um
in in even like the artistic kids like
there's a streak of like
you know um like they
like that they hate the tall poppy like
they you know the kids that stand out
paul poppy's gotta be cut down that like
cut down the tall
poppy just like a very it's a very
strange thing especially like
when you put all the artistic kids
together
you know there's jealousy and there's
anger
and you know you want to like
strike down the the exceptional ones
yeah and especially when it's kind of a
school full of already exceptional kids
who are already dedicated to this really
difficult
career path in the arts i imagine that
like anything
that makes you stick out it's like i
don't want to
yeah have anything to do with that so
did you so seeing all this
saying you know that you were seeing
homophobic homophobia
um you said there was homophobic
violence and things around you
did you feel comfortable pursuing
anything with girls
or not until i left not until i left i
mean not until
i uh was much older i think not until i
was like
in my late teens like i didn't really
pursue that until i was like 19
until i left school i mean there was
nothing like that until
i was much older because it was just not
safe at
school to want to be around that or to
want to be
um in a sense of like
of of like oh being in a relationship at
school or even with anybody at school
you know because it was just so like
creepy and weird and
also i didn't like anybody at school and
it was just like not not
just like weird creepy like drama kids
so no
so you said i mean you said that you did
have a boyfriend so when it came to like
boys and stuff were you
did you date them for like a long time
or was it just little flings
i had one boyfriend um so he and i dated
for
like a couple of years and then he had
he had cats um named prince and madonna
um wow was it related to the kids who
dressed as prince and
just now they're very related to the
kids they're separate and uh maybe it
was just
the times and then um
he uh he was very um androgynous
and um he had very long hair
and he wore a belt in his hair um
at the prom i just remember that he wore
like i had like one of those like very
large like
big wide belts you know those like big
white 80s belts and then
i took it off and he put it in his hair
um i remember at the prom
that was a thing um and uh
then um i i think
uh we ended up going to um yeah we went
to the prom
we went um we went out for a couple of
years
um he actually came over not that long
ago he
moved to ireland oh wow um i saw him not
that long ago he has children
he moved to ireland but uh he's he's a
he's a great
great guy um but he's not as on
androgynous now
now um but back then he was very very
uh girlish um
but it's a yeah it's i i think that i
didn't really
become sort of i i sort of identified
more um as a lesbian later i think i've
had a lot of lesbian feelings but i
didn't
identify more as a lesbian until i was
like 19
and then do you think you like kind of
swung
into the angry lesbian heavy clothes
phase because you had were like
i did the straight thing now i want to
go fully this like i want to go
all in on yeah i think it was like like
i think from 19 to 20 i was very lesbian
and then i was like tired of it and then
i was like
21 22 then i was like very um
then i went through like this weird like
ck1 phase
where it was like very like androgyny
and then i was like no this isn't good
because it was like more like style
phases
than it was really um
sexuality so it had more to do
with um fashion than i think
real feelings i mean listen i
i made a lot of fashion choices in my
youth as well i was like an emo kid so i
was like a little
yeah yeah my little like hot stuff
that's cool get ups and dyeing my hair
and stuff that was like my form of
rebellion um okay so we're coming
towards the end here
uh one question i wanted to ask you you
know you've been really honest about a
lot
of difficulties you went through during
this time
uh with like bullying and all different
things like that
did you have like an album
or a show or something that you
used as your like escape mechanism when
things got bad or crazy
um i think everything i mean i think
like cindy lauper for sure
cindy lauper was always really a great
um person to you know like
turn off to or she was her music was
always really um
a good friend and later she became a
friend
which is awesome that's so cool which is
super cool
but her music and her her energy
was really inspiring as somebody that
was such an
oddball who became an icon
that you could really survive uh being a
weirdo
and thrive from it you know so she was a
real sort of a lesson
in being yourself and uh really
becoming something magnificent because
of it you know because somebody's so
unique who was so special who was
absolutely
just once in a lifetime kind of creature
um once in a millennia kind of creature
who just became like this role model
really um you know like again like her
album she's so unusual was really like
something like
really moved me and changed me and
really made me believe that
you could really survive this and you
could really like
grow up and be okay and i think that um
she really is a symbol for all of us
like
all of us weirdos that you know we could
like survive it
and i think that you know like um
she really you know like her music and
her voice and her
image really was an enduring sort of
metaphor
and example of uh survival
so yeah i i think she was really
probably
really pivotal for me um if anybody i
would say her
uh joan jett also oh yeah um somebody
who was like
about power and strength and um
you know just that kind of like
female empowerment you know that through
all of that i think she was just some
it was like a knight in shining armor
that kind of like
shining leather kind of image she's
perfect
um so yeah those two women i think
really
um are really important to my
um to my imagination to who i
become and you know and also good
friends
now which is great so cool um okay
two three more questions one if you had
to
dress as either joan jett or cyndi
lauper for school every day which one
would you choose
i think joan jack joan jett is really i
mean although i do love cindy
cindy has a great style it's too very
different looks
but cindy you have to put on a lot of
stuff yeah with cindy it's actually
very it's quite curated cindy
it's like you it's a very careful it's
not just a bunch of things
it's like cindy went to art school so
it's like
it's quite difficult to get the balance
right
you know it's it's like it's it's in the
eye yeah it's really careful
and you're waking up so early to get to
school it's hard to
put together a full cindy whopper every
day so i would probably also go joan
jett
just because it's easier to maintain
joan jennings like you roll out of bed
joan jett it's kind of like you're just
cool yeah you know
you all you have to do is get like one
jacket and you're like yeah
every day and converse and it's the jojo
that's like the haircut
yes and it's like the eyeliner
and it's a leather jacket and jeans it's
just like it's just
being perfect and cindy it's like
it's like a different kind of perfection
but they're both cool
yes now when you are in a situation
where you're meeting
your you know idols from high school and
becoming friends with them
do you ever because i have this
sometimes now that i'm in comedy and i
get to
be on zoom chats with people like you
and stuff do you ever feel your high
school self like
being like oh my god i can't believe it
or like do you feel yourself making your
high school self proud
ever oh yeah totally i mean yeah
absolutely like i get very excited and i
get really
i mean i always you know i'm really
grateful you know and i
i definitely um you know
get very uh enchanted and you know i'm
thrilled about stuff and
um you know i'm really i want to tell
them and that you know i'm
always very encouraged and um
you know elated about it it's like very
it's a really important thing
so yes all right well margaret this has
been amazing we always end the show with
one final question
which is if you could tell teen margaret
anything what would you tell her
it's all going to be great
you literally nailed it
[Laughter]
the performing arts high school is going
to work out amazing it's going to be
amazing
that's awesome um well margaret it's
been
a thrill to talk to you you were a
wonderful guest
and for everybody at home this has been
the roast of your teenage self podcast
you